[Music]
how are you you look amazing what I love
about you is that you come year after
year after year too we day why do you
love this event so much I just know
everyone who's a part of this
organization for years now and I've
witnessed what they do and how they
celebrate young kids who are changing
the world completely just one step at a
time
and I come here and I cry at least twice
well yeah I do because it's so
encouraging to see that these kids are
working so hard and I would love for
that to spread all over our generation
and you do that too you worked so hard
to spread that positivity and we love
that about thank you I appreciate I
tried mm-hmm surprise for you she had
left you a little mouthing thank you so
much you're so amazing you're so
beautiful
such a pretty girl
I love that literally could not stop
flashing about yo I'm obsessed with her
she is so sweet and she's very honest
and I respect that
what does that friendship mean here it's
great because I I felt like when we got
to work on the video we were able to be
there for a while and there was no
pressure everything was super laid back
I just think she's hilarious and she
brings a fiery and energy into anything
you always inspire and encourage your
female friends cardi Taylor you excited
for her music oh yeah oh my goodness
it's amazing just wait
[Music]